so if you ever have one of those bosses
that tells you what to do six things
today and tomorrow he's like here's six
more ideas and the next day you're like
here's six more ideas instead of just
saying like yes sir ask a follow-up
question and just say where do you want
me to put that on our list of priorities
it'll cause them to pause and say wait
what else do you have on your list and
then be like well here's the six things
you told me yesterday and the four
things from the day before they're like
oh yeah don't worry about those this is
the new priority you'll be able to see
how they think through priorities so
you'll be more aligned with the
long-term vision of the company but then
they'll also see that you're thinking
strategically because you're actually
doing what most people don't which is
trying to prioritize activities and if
the person switches priorities all the
time that's the boss for now and maybe
long term you want to find a different
boss but at least you'll be doing the
thing that matters most at that moment
and they'll know you are